I decided whenever I send out the
challenge giving me the white pieces so
all right let's go I want to play maybe
whoa Marshall defense is what they're
calling it d0 six Queens gambit declined
Marshall defense I don't know about this
one not sure about the marshal defense
here just night here pawn push should I
be preventing pawn push I'm gonna
prevent pawn push okay okay I don't
worry about the bishop coming out here
where's he going to go then it's a big
question I don't know if black has a
good answer to that where is he going to
go if he's not going to call it here
what and how is this pond these are this
is another question how is this pawn
structure that I have in the center
going to be challenged would seem as
though c5 is the only thing so my
natural reaction was just Knight c3 but
is it worth considering Bishop here I
think it could still be played and if i
take the Queen's come off i Mun castled
and then night to a four hits c5 a
second time along with the b2 pond so
for that reason I think it is best just
bring that night out and then if c5 is
played I could be playing this but it's
not played so how is this Center going
to be challenged then if this pod can't
contribute and what is this guy going to
do and if he can't do anything what is
he going to do what does my light square
Bishop want to do Bishop here just
development I have a space advantage so
playing here is just welcomed welcoming
dark square Bishop exchange reinforce my
deep on I'll want to be cautious of a
night playing to a five and then to this
square I think this is maybe blacks
beste
try Knight a5 I'm c44 night and
preparing this advance I really don't
know though is f I'm gonna be played
might that be another pool way to strike
it my Center let us see ah f5 it seems a
bit crazy but maybe that's okay should I
be crazy play g4 seems a little weird
might there be something to it though
just so I could take and then take and
then pawn push cuz what else is my
opponent going to do I have a nice
center so i could be looking at play on
the wings maybe Queen d2 first Brooks
look here I really don't know let's see
where the Kings gonna go it's very very
very committal to do something like g4
mm-hmm I'm very tempted to do it very
committal but i'm very tempted by that
mouth I'm gonna try it what am I no no I
think this is gonna be a good response
let's let's play it safe no need to get
crazy this will be sufficient enough
here we go we had a f5 did I call that
one or did I call that one keep it
closed f4 I have covered my queen is on
d two queens on d2 and it's been a while
since I ran a stream it's been a while
ah very good very very very very very
very good a lot of areas there h4 let's
trade dark square Bishop since my pawns
are on dark I want to let my night sit
sit night so if it's challenge that's ok
if it's captured I recaptured the pond
and then I could eventually control d5
this is a week square time is an issue
30 where did my time go was there no was
there a glitch was our glitch glitch a
[ __ ] I really oh I just want to take
that guy take him out do I still just
want to play here some sack I'm not
liking my position all of a sudden not
liking it okay okay let's try this I'm
afraid of F for fearing f4 yes I am
fearing f-for what a silly mood would
have to make I don't know if I had to do
a but I'm gonna do it now h 5 night here
night there maybe that was most direct
i'm still not castled i don't know if i
want to even castle not considering
kingside castles age 59 age 496 I should
be throwing those moves up really quick
if Knight takes bishop I think I take
with my pawn and then King to f2 would
be nice home taking with my pawn
provides a nice grip / f 40 now that is
what you call a pain yeah that is
definitely a pain yeah that's a pain be
feeling the pain here that Bishop is
going to be on c6 what happened to my
position I should have considered g4 yep
Bishop c6 I need to move my rock get
that rig out of harm's way before it's
too late
ah man my opponent is having a field day
on this d 5 square look at how they're
just pivoting about with their minor
pieces the Queen the bishop the Knights
all of them are having a lot of fun
they're laughing at me laughing at me
they're saying you weekend d5 like that
you dummy you dummy see how f5 influence
the d5 square made by epon flinch now
what what else is there besides Bishop
c6 you played there to play here is
something like this being considered or
Bishop takes Knight are they fearing
night g6 nonsense hmm think I might
still want to go there Bishop here boom
chop chop Queen here chop chop chop on
h6 mates for the mates ah or that move
or that move on unexpected an unexpected
shot I'm a dead man I'm a dead man haha
oh no no no no no no okay I gotta go
here I got to give up my bishop ah man
f4 brutal no you can't be dropping
pieces on your birthday don't do it you
can do it come back don't you dare give
up now I want to come back here I'm not
going to take the rook if the bishop
place here im gonna play here oh come on
you're supposed to win all your games on
your birthday it's not my birthday yet
it's not midnight I got another hour for
that don't make me cry my birthday haha
okay let's do this I'm feeling still
pretty comfortable I have a giant
actually that's a that's an exaggeration
there I really feel comfortable I feel
comfortable here I was going to say it's
kind of comfortable knowing I have all
these ponds around pawnees
night f4 it's a reliable home isn't it I
don't I really don't even want to take
that rook I'm not going to take them if
I have the opportunity to take them I'm
not going to take them I just want you a
castle now Bishop here fish no it's not
a fishing pole not a fishing pole what
are you talking about oh now I have to
worry about the bishop coming here
anymore it's gotta be good whoa hang on
to that pond time time time time back up
the bishop look for Queen 2h7 battery
city looking for the batteries the
bishop the bee battery in the queue
battery right here is the leader um just
move you have time to think Queen d2
looking for tricky mates Queen trade no
no no no no no no throw in a check let's
hit the Queen again and then throw this
in check just anything just anything
move rook if the rep moves it's me just
anything Oh down to the wire down to the
wire good game time is up for Team black
ok ok ok ok ok let me flip that board f4
was an excellent shot yepper excellent
shot let me go back let me flip the
board and let's see how I could do
better what I was talking about f5 the
whole time well tonight and then it was
played and then my epon flinches and
then again my opponent is a becomes
thoroughly excited about the d5 square
the pieces jumping around on it so I
mean what's the scoop here this is a
nice center isn't it where'd it go wrong
we're to Quahog where's the improvement
where's the improvement it's just like
okay you can't how you going to
challenge us I was talking about f5 is
something like g4 really is that really
the way to go about things or why am I
not considering d5 is the matter with me
you could play d 50 wine i play d5 hmm
ok well i'll be looking into d5 yeah you
know now it's a bit too late yeah it's
definitely a bit too late now because
there's chop and this guy girl runs wild
a lot quicker d5 takes i take the night
you take that or something I don't know
so I think I looking into d5 a bit
sooner was the way to go here right
after castle I think right now push take
take the night has to go I guess here
but you know well and then my palm to be
hit three times but I think after rook
here you know now I'm in a spot to be
able to kick that night on be far away
anyhow I think that that's how that's
something I should certainly be looking
into and I didn't even consider it
during the game just expanding in the
center putting these guys to use not
having him just sit there in other words
and have them look pretty but put it in
putting him to work that's one of the
advantages and I didn't even I don't
know why I wasn't even thinking about
pushing him forward I guess I wanted to
maintain them right there on the fourth
rank but d5 I think now things turn this
is a great home and how should my
opponent have a beat me up here boom
nice shot bishops dead how do you beat
me here how do you beat me how about
considering Bishop g5 give up a rook
this is still minor piece land right
here not really a whole lot that extra
Brook could be you know can't put that
rip to use the two minor pieces will
dominate
a rook so I think maybe consider Bishop
here putting pressure on this pawn
taking here I think only benefits me
because then I could eventually control
d5 with my sepan so I don't know that
this helps maybe Bishop here right away
is best and what I have been planning is
just night coming back here because
otherwise if Bishop g5 Knight takes rook
well first off you could actually take
this pun with the bishop and in between
move so that's it that's actually a big
issue isn't it yeah i think i'd be need
to come back so I'm thinking Bishop g5
in this in this position don't even take
don't allow me to even think about
controlling d5 at some point have the
rook lift still kind of tough what's the
pond scum one two three six versus six
on seven yeah i mean this is this is
still it's must still be good for you
but LightSquared bishop is not too happy
now with the c6 most there's got to be
something else he could be doing maybe
just take the night and then play Bishop
c6 and then try and get over here
against my king or it's very very holy
over here a lot of lot of holes going on
okay good game let me close out